eq l'invité politique de la matinale
puisque ce matin andré bonnet adjoint à
la culture à la mairie de perpignan est
avec nous andré bonnet bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france quatre arrêtés
municipaux ont été signés hier par votre
mère louis aliot pour officialiser la
réouverture des musées aujourd'hui la
préfecture elle a déposé un recours
du coup qu'est ce que vous nous dites ce
matin est ce que les musées vont rouvrir
aujourd'hui
bonjour d'abord oui les musées vont
ouvrir à partir de 11h je regrette que
roselyne bachelot qui a mobilisé une
centaine de conservateurs de musées de
france et oublier celui de perpignan
d'autant que notre exposition
actuellement un événement d'une grande
exposition que nous avons monté avec le
musée de versailles est une exposition
totalement exemplaire des rigaud jamais
exposé dans le sud de la france son
entité donc le musée de versailles pour
rejoindre la capitale du roussillon et
aurait été sympathique que notre musée
soit associée aucune démarche
politicienne de la part de delio
simplement ma demande culturelle qui
nous sommes engagés dans une brèche
puisque la ministre a proposé hier de
précipiter le dispositif d'ouverture des
musées et je ne vois pas pourquoi
maintenant viendrait nous reprocher de
mener une réflexion adultes et citoyenne
avec l'ensemble des cadres et des
personnels de nos musées qui sont vous
pouvez l'imaginer satisfait de ces
ouvertures de musée nous avons
évidemment bien en place toutes les
dispositifs tous les dispositifs
sanitaires de manière extrêmement
strictes pour que personne ne prenne le
moindre risque dans nos quatre musées
donc ne faisons pas un mauvais procès à
perpignan au contraire on devrait plutôt
saluée
initiative qui s'inscrit justement dans
la démarche positive de la misère
culture aux bachelot qui a mis cette
belle idée de précipiter le calendrier
d'ouverture des musées regardez
justement ce qu'a déclaré roselyne
bachelot la ministre de la culture un
musée ça ne s'ouvre pas comme on allume
la lumière dans une pièce mais les
musées les monuments seront les premiers
convoqué à la réouverture
quant aux salles de spectacles et de
cinéma nous n'en sommes pas encore là
alors il faut une quinzaine de jours
pour ouvrir un musée a dit donc
roselyne bachelot ça fait longtemps vous
avez pris cette décision de rouvrir les
quatre musées de perpignan
on en parle tous les jours avec l'audio
on est évidemment au chevet du monde
culturel à perpignan nous avons ici ce
magnifique musée nous avons une scène
nationale avec le théâtre de l'archipel
nous avons ce festival exceptionnel visa
pour l'image
nous sommes en permanence en contact non
seulement avec les conservateurs de
musée mais évidemment avec l'ensemble
des acteurs culturels de notre ville
donc évidemment cette ouverture des
musées ça fait des jours et les jours
qu'on en parle et la ministre a donné le
top départ hier donc aucune décision ou
attitude provocatrice notre pas
simplement salué son initiative de
vouloir ouvrir le musée et nous de
manière expérimentale ce n'est pas 15
jours près dans la mesure où tous les
dispositifs sanitaires surpris ouvrons
nos musées et permettant justement
d'utiliser à bon escient l'argent public
quelqu'un les vraies dispositions coûts
et à lyon près d'un million de francs 1
million d'euros aux contribuables
et si nous précipitons pas l'ouverture
des musées elle va repartir et personnes
ravies cette exposition et ça sera de
l'argent qui aurait été jeté par les
fenêtres mais c'est vrai c'est ce qu'on
a à 15 jours près finalement pourquoi ne
pas avoir attendu la décision
gouvernementale parce qu'on considère
que de cette décision la ministre est
intervenu hier et ce délai
supplémentaire duquesne deux jours n'a
pas de dettes
elle aurait dû au contraire d'apporter
un message fort nous sommes car en
période
vacances et ça aurait permis justement
aux parents d'accompagner donc leur
enfant est de visiter ces musées dont ce
délai supplémentaire de quinze jours à
notre avis ne tient pas debout alors
l'acteur pierre niney lui aussi avait
interpellé la ministre de la justice
regard des 100 jours sans aucun musée
mais avec tous les lieux de culte 100
jours sans aucun cinéma mais avec tous
les grands magasins cent jours sans
aucun théâtre mais avec tous les avions
où l'on mange en même temps cent jours
d'incompréhension une incompréhension on
imagine que vous partagez à la mairie de
perpignan
on l'a partagée moi je lance un appel à
roselyne bachelot j'me dis je le demande
de levée se délite complémentaire de 15
jours et de nous aider à tous les musées
de france d'ouvrir comme nous faisons
aujourd'hui à perpignan et ça permettra
dans cette période de vacances scolaires
d'apporter véritable espoir culturel à
notre jeunesse qu'elle a bien besoin
alors la ministre de la culture a
cependant fermé la porte à une
réouverture prochaine des salles de
spectacles ou des cinémas qui n'ont pas
rouvert on le rappelle depuis la fin du
iième confinement est ce que à perpignan
on pourra aller bientôt au cinéma ou
voir une pièce de théâtre mais je
l'espère de tout mon coeur nous pour
l'instant nous sommes concentrés sur
l'ouverture de nos musées et puis
ensuite il y aura une réflexion plus
élargie sur le soutien
monde culturel il faut maintenant qu'il
y ait des actes il faut maintenant qu'on
sorte de cet isolement parce que je
crois que les jeunes un peu plus les
gens ont besoin de culture est en
réflexion la plus élaborée dans le cadre
d'une contrainte et d'une sécurité
sanitaire la plus sûre possible il faut
que les choses bougent et il faut
maintenant que les leviers saute pour
permettre donc à notre pays de retrouver
à la fois les chaînons comme vous le
dites des salles de cinéma ou du
spectacle
en quelques mots pour conclure on lisait
la préfecture a donc déposé un recours
le tribunal de montpellier
il doit s'exprimer quand dans la journée
normalement dans la journée on verra que
le tribunal nous donnera raison
en tout état de cause ce délai de 15
jours de roselyne bachelot est
totalement incompréhensible et je pense
que l'agenda
il ya une erreur dans le take d'agenda
l'agenda d'amis niçois va lui coller
comme je voulais dit tout à l'heure avec
cette période de vacances scolaires si
le tribunal de montpellier vous dites
fermées vous fermer aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas dans les surrection nous nous
déplorons cette décision et nous et le
maire de perpignan travail ses
responsabilités mais je lui laisserai la
primaire de s'exprimer merci beaucoup à
vous andré bonnet d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl frange le rappelle vous êtes adjoint
à la culture à la mairie de perpignan